Napoleon was an incredible strategist
Your Majesty we are discovered good they
put an encampment about 5 10 km in from
of the Russians right on the edge of the
lake which is frozen so the Russians
attack wait let them think they have the
higher ground he hit thousands of
infantry coming in from the Left Flank
send in the Infantry take their position
on the higher ground at the Double from
the right flank is the Cavalry Cavalry
from the West Pi's their flank who push
them onto the lake ni it's a
TR
then M shells the
lake so efficient he's like a real
wolf I'm not built like other men I'm
destined for greatness Napoleon
exclusively in theaters tickets on sale
now r
r